all right i want to follow up this neil
cavuto thing has gotten really really
interesting
yesterday we talked about fox news host
neil cavuto
literally begging his audience
supplicating saying get vaccinated stop
the politicization of vaccines
and he has been essentially ignored by
his entire network now neil cavuto is in
a particular health situation neil
cavuto has had multiple sclerosis for
quite some time he had heart surgery he
was vaccinated when he recently got
coveted and he attributes having as mild
the case as he did
statistically he attributes it of course
it's all anecdotal individually but
statistically he attributes it to being
vaccinated so we looked yesterday at
multiple clips of him
pleading with his audience here is one
such example as a reminder to get us all
on the same page we've lost 5 million
globally to this we've lost nearly 800
000 in the us take the political
speaking points and toss them for now
i'm begging you toss them and think of
what's good not only for yourself but
for those around you if you don't want
to do it for yourself if you think it's
a pain in the ass i get that right but
think of others around you i dare say
people who experience this or see loved
ones who've been affected by this or
have never died from this are not
judging the wisdom of mandates they're
wishing they got vaccinated and they
didn't i'm so lethargic
so we suspected that based on the
reaction from other shows which was
to say nothing about this shows on fox
to say nothing about this and just keep
hammering about vaccine mandates and
protests and all of this different stuff
we suspect that it that his audience
might not like this and in fact that's
the case so yesterday there were some
responses to neil cavuto
begging his audience about the vaccine
shared and some people in his audience
want him dead now i
i receive death threats all the time on
this show and and many people in media
do
um but it's interesting that
his own right wing audience which he has
fed he's built this monster over the
last however many 20-plus years that
he's been on fox news i think
um they very quick the people that want
me dead are never people that were on my
side
um the people that seem to want neil
cavuto dead
are people that were fine with him they
were viewers of his show so let's take a
look at it he shared some of these um
yesterday
uh we've got a tj who also emails it's
clear you've lost some weight with all
this stuff good for you but i'm not
happy with less of you i want none of
you i want you gone dead kaput finite
get it now take your two-bit advice
deep six it and you wow that's uh rather
harsh neil so
uh but i figured i'd relate to you for
the sopranos uh prequel yes it does
sound kind of like that okay now we got
vince
vince tweets hey guys i bought a new car
after being told it was the best then i
blew up after i left the car lot so now
i'm begging everyone to please buy the
same car sorry i would just pretend to
be neil cavuto so i guess that the
implication is cavuto only wants other
people to get
the vaccine
because he got it and the vaccine is
terrible so he wants other people to
experience the same bad stuff i mean
it's crazy it's it it's bizarre which i
think is uh being a little uh sarcastic
there in that last tweet
you think a little bit a little bit
better a little bit okay a little bit i
know you love that the cringy nature of
the segment is not lost on me by the way
another tweet plitter fact politifact
bias neil cavuto has been fully
vaccinated for months and has been a
vocal advocate about the safety and
efficacy of covet vaccines publicly and
repeated repeatedly on air this is not a
new position for him which is true neil
this is not a new position and that's
kind of what we were stressing you know
seriously look this is something from
the very beginning i've been saying that
i think the better part of valor is if
you haven't been vaccinated it might be
a good idea for you to get vaccine i
understand those for religious personal
reasons don't want it but i understand
also the numbers now remember we dealt
earlier with the religious thing there's
almost no religions that actually ban
vaccination and the ones that do are not
prominent religions for the most part in
the united states or we do get
vaccinated the the bigger the drop in in
cases absolutely yeah didn't fall on all
receptive ears no clearly not i got
another one for you from ignis uh
aspiring to aspire tweets cavuto is the
tigger of talking heads a head full of
fluff just not the not cool like tigger
and i think for the record we had our
fact checkers look at this i think she
is actually referring making the
correlation that you were like pooh bear
because he poo was the one that was full
of fluffs okay all right so now they're
getting off into into very strange stuff
so what's funny is maybe this is new for
neil but this is my inbox every day okay
let's put that aside what's not funny
is that part of this reaction to neil
cavuto saying get vaccinated you know
take the politics out whatever
part of it
is a result
of coverage that neil cavuto has done
and in fact
yesterday he did a story
uh about
vaccine mandates triggering protests he
did he he signal boosted again
that there are these wacky people going
to rallies merely to advocate against
vaccination and the fact that that's
gotten non-stop coverage on fox news is
part of what has built this monster so
maybe don't cover that neil particularly
since he supposedly does sort of more of
like a finance based show i mean
so i i i think it's a great thing that
neil cavuto is um saying this on fox
it's an audience that desperately needs
to hear it i'm not surprised that his
audience turned on him listen trumpists
what was the thing that got trumpus to
turn on trump
at that rally in
i don't even remember was it georgia was
it wisconsin a couple months ago when
trump said i recommend the vaccine and
freedom too but i recommend it
that that
completely vile committed trumpist
audience booed trump so we know that
this is something that will get the
crowd to turn on you uh but you can't
ignore the fact that neil cavuto has
also participated in some of this very
same stuff through the story choice that
he's done on his program so that's
what's going on not a big shock that
this is the way that his audience is
reacting
one of our sponsors is sheath underwear
it's summer right now in the northern
hemisphere it's hot it's humid many of
the men in my audience know about the
discomfort that can come with this with
traditional underwear the sweating the
chafing the sticking not fun and that's
what sheath underwear has solved sheath
has designed men's boxer briefs with
multiple ergonomic compartments built
into the front of the underwear which
keeps everything separate dry cool and
comfortable all day long sheath has
re-released two limited edition styles
flower of life with a stylish
flower pattern and bold geometric
waistband the other limited edition
style is the mesh airflow especially
designed to be lightweight and promote
extra coolness and breathability
give sheath underwear a try i've had a
great experience with it i think you
will too you can find the link
underneath this video and don't forget
to use promo code pacman for 20 off